E aí
[Música]
Olá
eu sou santo
É
mas eu não nasci Santo
a primeira coisa que eu lembro que eu vi
em todo lugar
e era você é um menino sensível demais
a vocação de casa tinha uns três anos e
meu padrasto chegou um ano e meio depois
e eles me deram da melhor forma do jeito
que puderam como aprenderam e que
conseguiram construir acima disso o
melhor que podiam fazer e também junto
com isso a fotografia aqui para mim
começou a formar e fazer sentido e
sentir para o que é pai amigo homem
força melhor rápido bom ideal e esse
lugar sentir não pude resistir
e eu levei isso para mim eu no começo
entreguei tudo da melhor forma que eu
recebi depois disso eu comecei a
reproduzir em cima disso e acabei
ficando bem bom
e
depois essa fase Eu acho que eu comecei
a fazer carreira solo
o e construir em cima do que eu achava
que era bom ser homem ser forte ideal
justo e principalmente não fosse
sensível demais
e eu
eu já tinha a família dois filhos Maria
e Rodrigo eu acho que eu volto a falar
deles
é casado já era líder em organizações
que trabalhavam
o e
buscar cada vez mais e melhor esse lugar
e eu acho que eu dei menos
espaço para esse sentir
em nenhum momento Ele cobrou essa conta
para existir Eu Fui internado porque eu
usei droga fiquei quatro meses numa
instituição e quando eu cheguei lá tudo
que era valor tudo que era potência tudo
que era riqueza tudo que era ser homem
não pode entrar comigo eu lembro de
escrever no caderno que foi o primeiro
pior dia da minha vida porque eu acho
que eu entrei sem identidade
e eu achei que fosse morrer mas eu não
morri
e naquele lugar you uma política
totalmente diferente cheio de homens que
eram falidos como eu
o sistema de troca de diálogo ali abriu
espaço para eu poder sentir de novo
eu lembro do Brasília
franzino Magrinho careca Eu já recebia
os recém-chegados no quarto um eu sentei
Enquanto o outro menino fazia pesquisa e
ele fumava um cigarro com uma cara
sinistro ficava me olhando de repente
bateu a cinza assistir um ritual falei
definitivamente vou morrer
E aí todo mundo tinha medo dizia que ele
vem andando de Brasília essas histórias
que contavam
depois de uns 2 meses ali já eu nunca
tinha visto Brasília falar nada mas hoje
eu sentei do lado deles meninos tava
jogando futebol Ele tava sozinho e eu
falei Brasília se tu mata tu vai matar
porque eu vou sentar aqui então vai
ficar sozinho
e ele não falou nada a gente possa aqui
no futebol acho que umas duas horas pelo
menos eu morri
hoje à noite quando foi mais ou menos 1
e 6 da manhã ele bateu na minha janela e
falou quero conversar com você
e quando a gente foi lá fora ele me
abraçou e começou a chorar e disse que
pensa que eu não sei só não acha que eu
sou louco Pensa que eu não sei que todo
mundo tem medo de mim mas na verdade eu
sou um bundão e começou a chorar eu
escuto vozes eu tenho medo acho que todo
mundo tá vindo atrás de mim mas quando
eu sair lá de Brasília com 9 anos para
rua porque a situação é da família
tradicional brasileira pelo menos aqui
eu conheço de onde vim
e ele teve que representar esse papel
para propor medo e para propor e se
sentir quando eu sair de lá depois de
experimentar um lugar onde o menino
Sensível Demais talvez pudesse existir
de novo com caras que não deviam nada e
nem naquele lugar exatamente a qualidade
desse nada é que eu queria observar é
como eu cheguei lá e achei que não tinha
mais nada qualquer coisa que acontecia
ali e fazer existir de novo sentir
quando eu sair de lá eu decidir eu ia
fazer tudo o que fosse possível e
necessário para sentir trabalho relações
família meus filhos eu precisava Existir
nesse lugar que eu aprendi ali
e lembra de um sonho
Oi Sara uma figura feminina hoje a mão
no meu ombro
entre um monte de coisas bonitas que ela
disse ela me empurrou no final e falou
levanta que agora tu se chama Santo
e no final Ela disse o que eu trouxe
e agora tu vai ver no mundo o que o teu
coração
achava ser impossível existir
e depois desse sonho só sei que essa
ativação me fez decidir
existir esse lugar e surgiu o símbolo
ativista docente na mudei minhas redes
sociais mudei meu trabalho comecei a
querer me relacionar mais com que era
esse lugar eu nunca tinha deixado meu
cabelo crescer sou de família pobre
nasce um Cortiço preto e nunca vi meu
cabelo crescer
é E essas experiências eu lembro um
dinheiro uma notícia pintando uma vela
de um barco de um Capitão do quarto
menor país do mundo e eu respirei abrir
o braço e sentir o vento no meu cabelo
pela primeira vez
Bom dia 28 de Maio de 2018 a primeira
primeiro eu pintei na primeira tela
O Tata minha companheira me levou
comprei do três guaches dois Pincéis e o
papelão que forra o chão de pintura Eu
lembro que quando coloquei o pincel
naquela parede
e eu falei em voz alta O que é que eu
não fiz isso antes a
eu
acredito que
muito próximo dentro da experiência do
que eu nunca fiz antes pode abrir um
diálogo inclusive para essas minhas duas
partes surgirem
E aí
e
eu cansei de existir no lugar onde a
minha figura a minha força a minha
assistência precisa conquistar a sua
é preciso influencia a sua
e eu acho que quando eu pinto
o menino sensível demais
Oi pode trazer o que um coração dele já
sabe que é possível existir
mas eu não sou da escola da arte eu não
tenho familiares artistas
mas quando eu pinto
e eu descubro
o chat pode ser também
e o essencial de alguém existe através
de se sentir sem limite
e a partir disso
eu não sei se eu tenho uma resposta nem
me interessa conquistar
e o entendimento
Ah mas eu quero para propor
é uma experiência que abre essa porta
é que além do sentimento
e essa consciência do sentido pode
existir e reformar forma que a gente
fala a forma que a gente sente percebe
troca a forma que a gente entende
e eu vou te convidar a fechar o olho
a respirar
a respirar fogo
e solta esse ar
se levanta o teu queixo a confeccionar
isso Horizonte
e abre teu olho
o e nunca mais dúvida do que o teu
coração acredita existir
bom obrigado
E aí
[Música]